hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
here at google cloud in this video we're
going to take a look at what might be
the quickest way to move workloads
running in vms onto containers
specifically i'll be showing you how you
can utilize our migration tools to move
your existing vm based workloads to
cloud run google cloud's fully managed
serverless platform
[Music]
before we get into the details on
cloudrun and our migration tooling let's
level set by what we mean when we use
the term serverless serverless platforms
allow developers to abstract
infrastructure management for a simpler
developer experience with serverless
tools tasks like managing the underlying
infrastructure are handled by google
cloud this infrastructure scales
dynamically as needed by handling these
day-to-day tasks you're freed up to
focus on additional value added tasks
which can ultimately increase your speed
to market
cloudrun allows you to develop and
deploy highly scalable containerized
applications on a fully managed
serverless platform that allows you to
deploy containerized workloads in
seconds
in addition to reduced complexity
cloudrun also offers several key
benefits including increased security
via automatic https and flexibility with
custom domains
you can write your code using your
favorite language go python java ruby
and more
it's built upon the container and k
native open standards enabling
portability of your applications
and you can abstract away all
infrastructure management for simpler
developer experience
when looking at modernizing existing
workloads i like to break it down into
two big buckets the first is the
modernization of the underlying
infrastructure such as running workloads
on cloud run
the second is modernizing your existing
workloads one way to do that is to take
an application that is running inside of
a vm and convert it to run inside of a
container
migrate for gke and serverless is a set
of services that helps with that process
by automating a significant chunk of
that work
when looking at migrating an existing
workload there are four discrete steps
that you'll want to go through
first discovery and assessment migrate
has a fit assessment tool that can be
used to help identify what workloads you
have running and which are best
candidates for migration take a look at
our fit assessment video for more
information
next is the setup and planning phase
migrated workloads can be run on
cloudrun as well as in gke in standard
or autopilot mode or on anthos
additionally you can orchestrate
migration pipelines to help automate the
migration process
in this video we're focused on the third
phase so i won't spend a lot of time on
it right here
the final phase deals with how you
manage applications after they've been
migrated because migrate for gke and
serverless provides you with the
resulting docker file you can easily
manage updates to your code via standard
deployment pipelines
to illustrate how migrate for serverless
works with cloudrun i'm going to show
you a demo of taking a django
application's web front end from a vm
and running it on cloudrun we're
actually joining the migration process
in the middle the application was
originally a monolithic vm that had a
front end and the database running
together in the single vm
we used google cloud's database
migration service to move the database
to cloud sql and the web front end is
still in a vm
in this demo i'll use migrate for
serverless to move the django
application out of the vm and into a
container that i will deploy to cloud
run to start the demo i'll provide
migrate for gkn serverless a source vm
the migrate processes will inspect the
vm and then generate a migration plan
that i will add as needed from there it
will generate the deployment artifacts
including a docker container once we
have that container i'll deploy that to
cloud run with that background let's
take a look at the process in action
let's start by taking a look at our
application in action so it's basically
just a database of unicode characters so
if i click on the waving hand i can see
different characters for different
operating systems now because this is
django application we are using nginx
and g unicorn in tandem right where we
have g unicorn running on a socket and
we bind that to a port that nginx is
listening on we're going to need to
change that in our application and all
of that is being served out of this
virtual machine which i'm going to shut
down right now shutting down the vm is a
prerequisite to migrating it so let me
stop that vm
and we'll get on with the actual
migration
with the vm stopped let's go ahead and
create our migration so i'll click
create migration give the migration a
name select a source which i created
earlier choose linux system container
for the workload type the django gce
instance and we're just going to migrate
the base image so that's going to take
us a couple of minutes i'm going to go
ahead and stop the video and i'll join
you when it's finished all right we're
finished now so let me go ahead and
review and edit my migration plan the
first thing i need to do is i need to
set this value to true so that we can
use our enhanced run time and run on
cloud run i also want to disable all
these services some of these are used
for that g unicorn nginx
pattern that we talked about earlier
other are services that i don't actually
want to run in production such as ssh so
i'm going to disable all of these
and when i have all of those disabled i
can come down here and click save and
generate artifacts that's going to
generate the docker file as well as a
couple docker container images which i
will eventually deploy onto cloud run so
let me go ahead down here i'll click
save and generate artifacts again this
takes a little bit so i will fast
forward the video and rejoin you when
it's finished
okay we've generated those artifacts so
let's go ahead and move back over here
and take a look at what we've generated
so if i click on
review artifacts wouldn't come in and we
talked about before here's a dockerfile
kubernetes deployment spec as well as
the container image base layer and the
runtime layer so we're going to go ahead
and move into cloud shell here i'll use
mig-ctl to download my artifacts and i
can list them out here and you can see
them now
servicesconfig.yaml is a file that we
can use to define services that we want
to run in our new container and i'm
going to use that to define the g
unicorn service ingress so this replaces
sort of the systemd configuration we
looked at earlier
since i want to include this updated
services config in my new container i'm
going to go ahead and run cloud build to
rebuild my container image and that's
going to incorporate that services
config and give me a new version of my
container image that i can deploy into
cloud run so let's let this finish here
i'll speed it up a little bit
with that container image created let's
move into cloud run and create a new
cloud run service so we're going to come
in here we choose that container image
we just updated we're going to scroll
down and we're going to set an
environment variable
that environment variable tells cloud
run that we're using the enhanced
runtime from the migrate for containers
system so let's go ahead and set that to
true
then we're going to come in here we're
going to define the connection to our
cloud sql database
so we'll select that there and then
we're going to come in here and we're
going to allow unauthenticated
invocations so that we can reach the
service more easily
this will take a second to deploy so
let's let it run through its thing
we've got the url i'm going to paste it
up here and create a new tab let me grab
that
and new tab and there's our application
running on cloud run you can see
everything working as you would expect
it to
well i hope this video showed you how
you can use google cloud's migrate
tooling to move applications out of vms
and into cloud run for more information
check out our documentation and be sure
to like and subscribe so you'll be
alerted whenever we publish new content
[Music]